um let's keep talking to people because
there there are so many let's go next to
jate from tallahassee that's not jake
but jate with a t that's a that's
interesting
uh yes
or kind of like
nate but with a j that's another way to
put it that's actually much more clear i
think that that's even i would i will
say it that way from now on what's on
your mind jade
um i wanted to ask you about
the
um in florida
i'm seeing reports that there's
spanish language right-wing talk radio
in south florida
and it's having a
it's having a political effect
like i know there are a lot of
um exiled cubans who
seem to go pretty right-wing in reaction
to
cuba yeah they left cuba as well as
venezuela
it sounds like there are there's lots of
venezuelans who think the same way
as a spanish speaker do you have any
insights onto this phenomenon
so there's a few different things this
is a really good important and complex
issue and you know the the latino
electorate in american elections is
increasingly important and we've got to
figure this out because otherwise it's
not good for the left
so
generally speaking
immigrants to the united states from
latin america tend to vote for democrats
except the ones that don't
cubans
do not tend to vote for democrats cubans
are very republican
and they are republican um mostly as a
reaction to they say well castro
was bad and the opposite of castro is
republican so that's basically that
that's boiling it down to why that is
very similar thing with venezuela now i
as a leftist who is not a communist and
who does not like authoritarian
strongman regimes
my view is different my view is well
good okay you didn't like the regime in
cuba you left you didn't like the regime
in venezuela you left now you're in the
u.s
don't go for right-wing authoritarians
that's not the solution the solution is
social democracy which is my view but to
get to your point
when i did my spanish language show
around the 2020 election on the estrella
network
the amount of
conspiratorial thinking all of the same
conspiracies that we see on facebook in
english they were spreading like
wildfire within spanish language groups
in comments in response to the clips i
was doing the emails etc so
the best advice for the left would be
you need to understand that this is an
electorate that you need that we need
and you need to way more proactively be
going out there and preventing folks who
come to the us and just get in these
right wing latino echo chambers because
even if most of the voters tend to go to
the left
radio right-wing radio
right-wing spanish language radio in
florida
is influencing a lot of these folks who
are like well it's the one thing in
spanish so i'm going to listen to it and
it's wacky far right stuff and the left
has to figure out his strategy on it
yeah that's good i i didn't realize that
you had a spanish language um
show
in 2020 yeah we did like 13 weeks
basically like leading up to the
election and through the inauguration
uh very interesting yeah
you can even check out my spanish
language interview with
la mayor eric garcetti on my youtube
channel
oh unfortunately i would not be able to
understand it well it's subtitled don't
worry
oh oh yeah oh that's cool yeah
yeah as a
as a final thing um
i think i remember you talking about the
election fraud that occurred
now this is actually real election fraud
here in florida and that was when uh
some fake candidates were
were put up in the state legislature
yeah and the right term i mean calling
them fake is funny but it's they're so
they would be like straw candidates they
are candidates
made to take away votes from your
opponent and organized by a different
candidate yeah and that's against the
law to do
yeah
like i think you talked about it before
and you weren't sure what exactly had
happened
in terms of prosecution
but it looks like in one of the races
the they actually prosecuted
him for
for um i think some kind of campaign
finance violation and there was a former
state legislature legislator as well
yeah
and he pled guilty
in the race that the republican won by
32 points
not 32 points 32 votes 32 votes okay
yeah so he actually pled guilty and then
the article i just read said he was all
apologetic and stuff like that oh i'm
sure i'm sure well yeah i know and the
straw candidate thing we're going to be
watching it very closely in 2022. all
right my friend appreciate the call very
much
all right sure all right there we go